[Musique]
ce lundi 13 février dans le cadre d'une
manifestation dans les rues de
Saint-Denis l'intersyndicale agricole à
sollicité une rencontre avec le
président du département afin d'échanger
sur les difficultés rencontrées par la
filière fruits et légumes une délégation
a donc été reçue au palais de la source
dans la matinée à l'issue de leurs
échanges Cyril Melchior a exprimé sa
volonté de lancer un plan de soutien et
de relance pour la filière fruits et
légumes
longues rencontres rencontre
constructive dans un très bon état
d'esprit et je salue cet état d'esprit
où le dialogue prévôt nous avons bien
sûr examiné les difficultés
rencontrées aujourd'hui par les
différents producteurs il nous
appartient collectivement de duiano
efforts pour continuer à aider
l'agriculture réunionnaise face à la
crise et au cours des intrants qui
grèvent lourdement les producteurs de
fruits et de légumes nous allons mettre
en place un plan de soutien et de
relance
dédié aux filières fruits et légumes
avec des mesures concrètes rapidement
dans le courant du mois de mars on va
apporter les premières mesures pour
soutenir la rapidement face à la crise
il y a des sujets qui relèvent on va
dire de la responsabilité de l'État ne
sait que il y a eu une baisse au niveau
du fret et bien est-ce qu'on retrouve
ces mêmes baisses sur les prix de vente
des marchandises on y retrouve pas donc
il y a des effets de Ben certainement
des contrôles en la matière devraient
nous permettre d'Ivoire un peu plus
clair ainsi des mesures concrètes seront
proposées à court terme pour soutenir
les producteurs de fruits et légumes
face à l'inflation et un plan de relance
sera élaboré en lien avec les acteurs de
la filière pour proposer des solutions
plus pérennes
[Musique]